vamos a hacer una pausa en el análisis
de la situación de lo que se está
viviendo ucrania y vamos a analizar el
tema económico que es tal vez una de las
primeras señales de lo que se puede
venir sobre esta crisis económica a
nivel mundial está con nosotros en el
estudio daniel hablando de la redacción
económica de france24 daniela bienvenida
y comencemos por los indicadores cómo se
movieron las principales bolsas en la
jornada de hoy pues santiago hubo
sorpresas todo se imaginarían que todo
iba a estar en rojo pero ya le voy a
demostrar que no fue un bastante mal día
para algunos mercados bursátiles
iniciamos con rusia el índice principal
de la bolsa de moscú cayó 33 a 28 por
ciento pero llegó a bajar hasta un 45
por ciento y tuvo que suspender
operaciones en determinado momento en
europa hablamos santiago de los tres
países o tres mejor de los países con su
banca más expuesta a rusia que son
italia francia y reino unido- todos
tuvieron pérdidas de alrededor del 4%
ahora sí vamos a wall street' de ahí es
donde viene la sorpresa venía con esta
misma tendencia hasta que hablo yo bailé
índice nasdaq que es el que agrupa a las
tecnológicas por ejemplo se disparó en
casi un 4 por ciento y si nos vamos para
américa latina pues se contagió de nueva
york moderó sus pérdidas que tenía al
inicio de la jornada
hablemos ahora daniela de las sanciones
que impuesto occidente lo veíamos lo
analizamos al inicio del programa las
sanciones que han puesto eeuu y la unión
europea que el mismo presidente bardem
ha dicho que esto va a ser en un mediano
plazo esto no va a tener consecuencias
inmediatas pero qué es lo que han dicho
en materia económica pues anunció
santiago inicialmente de cuatro
sanciones contra cuatro grandes
entidades financieras rusas entre ellas
vtv que es el segundo mayor banco del
país también nuevos castigos económicos
a poderosos oligarcas cercanos al
kremlin en quienes no podrán ni siquiera
realizar transacciones con bancos
estadounidenses escuchemos lo y estamos
en un consenso completo limitaremos la
capacidad reducida de hacer negocios en
dólares euros libras y yenes hemos
congelado el banco ruso más grande que
tienen al menos un 30 por ciento de toda
la economía rusa por sí mismo la hemos
recortado el sistema financiero de eeuu
y hoy también estamos bloqueando cuatro
bancos más importantes eso significa que
cada bien que ellos tienen en eeuu será
congelado también anuncios santiago del
reino unido- lo que llamó el mayor
paquete de es que el kremlin haya visto
jamás vamos a ver dijo que congelará los
activos de los principales bancos
también legislará para impedir el acceso
a financiación de empresas rusas vetar a
la aerolínea aeroflot y limitar a los
depósitos de ciudadanos rusos en bancos
británicos además restringe las
exportaciones hacia rusia algunas de
estas medidas apuntan santiago
directamente a los oligarcas cercanos a
putin como por ejemplo quiere les llama
love quien es el multimillonario más
joven de rusia y es el ex esposo de su
hija catherine a pues esta fue la
respuesta también del presidente
vladimir putin quien se reunió con
empresarios sus rusia sigue siendo parte
de la economía global y dado que todavía
es parte de la economía global no vamos
a dañar el sistema en el que
participamos y creo que nuestros socios
deberían entenderlo y dejar de intentar
sacarnos del sistema pero aún así
pondrán esas restricciones por razones
políticas
daniela se ve todo de aeroflot la
aerolínea nacional rusa si hay una ruta
lucrativa para desarrollo línea es la
ruta moscú londres mueven muchísimos
pasajeros y carga ese veto va a
significar mucho de aeroflot y también
la ruta desde moscú a nueva york el
aerolínea tiene un mercado monopolio
completamente absorbido por ellos y eso
va a generar problemas económicos por lo
menos algunos números y le va a afectar
a la aerolínea rusa claro esto en cuanto
a rusia las consecuencias con estas
sanciones que le impone occidente pero
esto también afecta de alguna forma a
los ucranianos qué consecuencias
inmediatas va a sufrir este país pues
santiago es que como en todo conflicto
los primeros damnificados son por
supuesto los ciudadanos en este caso de
ucrania se comenzaron a ver largas filas
de gente tratando de acceder a sus
ahorros por ejemplo en donestsk muchos
de ellos están tratando de evacuar el
país con estos ahorros esto fue en un
pequeño pueblo llamado el lobby ians no
muy lejos de uno de los puntos más
intensos de las del ataque que está
llevando a cabo rusia también se prevé
desabastecimiento santiago porque hay
miles de personas intentando comprar
medicamentos y alimentos para
abastecerse en esta situación
abastecerse porque no saben cuánto va a
durar esta incursión militar pasemos
ahora al siguiente nivel de lo que de
traer esto en materia económica y son
las consecuencias a nivel mundial no
solamente europa no solamente el este de
europa se va a ver afectado esto va a
comenzar a volverse un efecto de bola de
nieve y también va incluso a golpearnos
en cierta forma que en américa latina'
claro que si santiago y es que nosotros
consultamos con varios expertos y la
mayoría coincide en que este abanico de
sanciones que no va a servir para
disuadir al presidente ruso de sus
ataques contra ucrania y lo que sí va a
hacer es afectar al resto de la
población consultamos con mauricio
cárdenas santamaría quien fue ministro
de hacienda de colombia y esto nos dijo
yo creo que hay dos elementos uno rusia
no es una democracia entonces la presión
que ciertos sectores
sectores empresariales sectores
económicos puedan hacer sobre putin para
que cambie su postura pues no es la
misma que ocurriría en una democracia
donde hay un presidente que tiene que
hacerse que hacerse elegir y que tiene
que responder a un electorado entonces
esa es una diferencia importante y
segundo
putin de haber calculado
cuál es su verdadera capacidad ofensiva
y por cuánto tiempo puedes sostener la
economía rusa y los ingresos para hacer
este tipo de agresiones militares no
creo que lo estén sorprendiendo
esas medidas daniela también importante
analizar la dependencia que tiene europa
del gas procedente de rusia son muchos
países de la unión europea que dependen
100% de el gas de la federación claro
santiago y otro aspecto muy interesante
en el que coinciden los expertos es que
justamente estas sanciones no solamente
van a afectar al que las recibe sino
también al que las impone y es que rusia
no es un gran país industrial y la
mayoría de sus ingresos proviene de
hidrocarburos y de alimentos europa es
un gran consumidor de petróleo y gas
ruso eso hay que decirlo hay países como
macedonia del norte que le importan todo
su gas o finlandia o letonia o serbia
que son casi dependientes alemania por
ejemplo importa la mitad de su gas desde
allí y francia- una cuarta de ahí lo
estratégico santiago del gasoducto nord
stream 2 cuya capacidad va a duplicar el
envío de gas hacia alemania y que ya
sabemos pues está construido desde el
año pasado pero no tiene todavía la
certificación alemana y es muy posible
que no la tenga en mucho tiempo en todo
caso hay pocas alternativas para llenar
el vacío si se interrumpe el suministro
de gas ruso a europa que importa el 60%
del hidrocarburo que consume aunque para
rusia también es un golpe no tener a
quien venderle su gas pues europa su
principal mercado algo parecido sucede
con el petróleo escuchamos que rusia es
un jugador muy importante en el mercado
de hidrocarburos digamos que su gran
relevancia desde el punto de vista
económico está en ese frente es el
tercer productor mundial de petróleo
después de eeuu y de arabia saudita pero
es un productor con la capacidad pues de
alterar lo que pasa en el mercado
petrolero a nivel global entonces bueno
esto va a afectar no sólo los ingresos
de rusia porque rusia deja de recibir
los ingresos por petróleo pero también
los consumidores mundiales que tienen
que pagar un precio por el petróleo la
gasolina el diésel etcétera y que otros
mercados cercanos no pueden suplir la
cantidad de petróleo de gas que necesita
la unión europea el mercado de
azerbaiyán no lo puede hacer que es un
país más o menos cercano y las sanciones
con irán tampoco le permite acceder
fácilmente a petróleo o gas de ese país
asiático pasemos ahora a analizar las
consecuencias que tiene para nuestra
región en américa latina' pues mire
parte de lo que decía el exministro de
hacienda mauricio cárdenas está
relacionado con el petróleo y es que por
ejemplo hoy la jornada si fue muy buena
para los commodities la referencia brent
e para el mar de europa pasó inclusive
los 100 dólares por barril un nivel que
no se veía hace más de 7 años y cerró
levemente el jueves por debajo de ese
valor escuchemos cuál es el análisis
también que hace él sobre cómo estos
precios del petróleo impactan
directamente américa latina'
ahora américa latina tiene el efecto
colateral de los mayores precios del
petróleo esto para países exportadores
de petróleo como méxico-colombia la
propia venezuela brasil
un poco argentina y pues son efectos
positivos pero al mismo tiempo hay un
efecto negativo y es la falta de
confianza en la economía global el
desaliento de la economía global que
obviamente juega en contra entonces yo
diría que hay un efecto positivo por un
canal pero hay efectos negativos por
otros y muchos también se estarán
preguntando qué va a pasar con las
monedas y es que las monedas también se
resiente en santiago yo no sé si usted
recuerda cuando usted estuvo en su vida
en suiza en rusia cuánto le daban por un
dólar en ese momento a mí me tocó un
boom petrolero precisamente en rusia
entonces el rublo ruso era carísimo no
recuerdo tanto pero pero pero era muy
caro pues mire este jueves llegó un
mínimo histórico llegó a caer 45 % hasta
los 85 rublos por cada dólar eso es un
mínimo histórico y esto tiene una
explicación santiago y es que los
inversionistas saca todo lo que tienen
en acciones y se meten en activos
refugio como el dólar o como el oro
inclusive y por eso es que suben los
precios de los commodities o el precio
del dólar es decir las monedas siguen
perdiendo valor contra el dólar y esto
seguramente va a seguir pasando y eso
afecta directamente el bolsillo de todos
ya pie daniela muchas gracias por este
reporte este completo análisis de la
situación económica de todo relacionado
en materia económica con esta invasión
militar de rusia al territorio ucraniano